It is,
I mean fucking president after this guy,
like the scrutiny that he's been under
and whether he deserves it or not,
I'm not saying he doesn't,
but who the fuck would want that
microscope up your ass? Yeah.
Who would want that?
I think it's an arrangement just like
him and stormy Daniels that she wanted a
job in the apprenticeship.
What I'm saying is like how will we going
to get another president like they're
going to do you know what
the fuck they're gonna,
they're gonna look up Kanye his ass with
a microscope and he's going to go crazy
again. He's gonna flip freak out
and go to some insane asylum.
Like he doesn't understand that
he's saying he treated, he was like,
does this look like the sunken place?
And it's just like his giant
corridor and his house and it's like,
I don't know dude. I think you're
like, oh cause from get out.
Cause that everyone's like,
dude, you're in the sunken place.
How many sinks down to the second place?
But he's like doubling down and he's like,
does this look like the sunken place?
And I was like showing his baller
house is baller house in hidden hills,
which is like, have you seen,
what does it mean? Um, Mayweather?
Is that the guy's name? Yeah, his lawyer
has a, Instagram is unbelievable. Dude.
He's great. He's all like, he's all like
wearing costumes and shit. He's like,
I'm the joker. And he's like,
dude, it's not even Halloween.
What are you doing please?
I'm having fun.
Just running around. What time? His
life before traumatic brain injury.
Not just joking. He doesn't even have
brain injury. It's fascinating about him.
He was whipped his ass because he's such
a good domestic. Whoa. Look at that.
He's such a good defensive.
This is counting as the breadwinner.
It says he's just sitting there counting.
Dude.
There's a hilarious photo of him like
sitting in the middle of just this huge
empty room and he's just like, I don't
even know his find the Kanye photo.
Terracycle dude Kanye. He's a trip.
He really is a trip and he's, he's,
whether he means to be or not,
he's a master at getting people
to pay attention to him. Whether,
whether this is just because he's so
wacky that everybody's paying attention to
him or whether it's a real calculated
sort of maneuvered to act outrageous and
act like he's out of control. But boys,
he fucking good at it. Here it is.
It's like, dude, do you
even have any furniture?
It was like a bench at the end of this.
A weird ass hoe.
This look like the sunken place
and he's crying. Laughing.
No, it looks like this.
Looks like a table. Kind of.
Looks like got some chairs.
You don't really have good
style. What the fuck? A whoa.
He's got a white torso in the
background. Scroll up again. But what,
what does that torso in the back row?
What's that?
Kim's like actually can we just get that
out of here? The waist is too thick.
Yeah. Can, can you give this thing light?
Libo a bigger ass. Give it a bigger ass.
So straight.
What is long ass open
space with white walls?
Suck it. Does this look
like the sunken place? Wow.
Fantastic. Um, babe, we had a rule
not to shore home on social media.
So can we now allow K U W K to keeping
up with the Kardashians filming in the
home?
This is so well,
so they're communicating only
through tweets. Yes. She's like,
come home and take care of the kids.
They've been winning now. Fucking genius.
Wow. Poor. But I'm not here blowing minds.
Do you like how Trump is so desperate for
attention that he was like, cool. Kanye,
Kanye. I was talking about how
I wanted Kanye or not Kanye.
I wanted, uh, to, to meet with Trump,
to see if I could talk him and it
actually fighting Joe Biden. I was like,
you're a businessman. You want to
make that? I'd be like, you're,
you're the best at everything. You
can be the best at fighting. Hey,
we're in a reality star culture. Why not?
Why not? How much I don't, first of all,
awesome Joe Biden's on death door.
All you have to do is have a stiff jab
and Joe Biden's going down. He's fucked.
You know, he could, Trump really
could win. It's take is just state.
Just ramp up the diet pills, choke him
with the hairpiece. Hairpieces fragile.
He can't.